let's do a page one analysis
for your movie electric love it's a
feature film
it's won many awards correct it did well
in the film festival circuit yes
yes excellent in this script we
immediately are introduced to emma
warren and she's sitting
in her car we don't know too much about
her um we just know she's in her 20s
sure she's putting makeup on uh can you
talk about why it was sort of a vague
description in the beginning
sure and uh before i have an answer i'm
very worried that screenwriters are like
you always do you were always meant to
do a character description
for some reason we don't we don't
exactly do that all the time
possibly because it's aaron and i you
know and so we're the ones creating the
script and we know exactly what we're
looking for and
you know we we know that the character
will be described via her
her dialogue you're absolutely going to
understand who this person is via
what she's about to say and what she
looks like you know that could
where we're kind of open to some
different different options there um
so i don't really have like a concrete
this is why we don't do it
i just kind of i'm probably leaning on i
don't know like i said i don't know this
is exactly like the writer's correct way
to do it but
we're just leaning into our instinct of
like we know what's going to happen with
this character
so we just kind of write her age and
maybe at best we'll write one little
marker like a notification of something
that she does or is wearing
but other than that we just kind of let
we try and let the dialogue just get us
there in the setting to get us there for
the for the script reader
okay so she's in a busy city maybe l.a
putting makeup
parked in a car that's stationary yes
talking to herself in the mirror
yes emma southern draw pardon me sir are
you the handsome gentleman whose photos
i came across upon my samsung galaxy
sorry i'm so bad i can't do it no okay
don't tell me
so emma how's the southern draw sure i'm
going to
leave that to interpretation of somebody
else so i'll just do emma
pardon me sir are you the handsome
gentleman whose photos i came across
on my samsung galaxy now quick question
sure
is that because you have product
placement i think that
uh we were probably hoping to get
product placement on the same thing
uh we did not so we changed that to
cellular device oh you did okay
right okay great so great now did you
write
this opening dialogue or did your
writing partner aaron oh my goodness
you know you always think you're going
to know exactly which words you wrote
and which ones your partner wrote and
i'm like who did write that whose idea
was it that she's putting on this little
accent i want to say it was aaron's
because really the genesis of electric
love
all was with aaron he had all types of
uh
tinder experiences um that he told me
about and i was
like oh i didn't really have those
experiences and that was you know i
think that's just the plight of
men versus women in a busy city where
dating apps exist
um and so it was his idea to do a sort
of dating app
focused comedy rom-com and i came on
board and i was like oh it sounds like a
lot of fun let's do it i did my best you
know to try and like breathe like my own
personal point of view into the emma
warren and or
any of the female characters um but i do
want to say it was aaron i think it was
aaron he's very fun like that so he he
has her
do this like southern twang a couple
times as like a silly
character thing that she does every now
and then so like a blanche
dubois yeah
[Applause]
okay we'll have you read it so then
after this opening she takes out her
phone and she records herself
singing and then emma and then she says
it i think her normal voice and she says
this is emma warren on friday december
3rd at approximately 4 p.m
if i am raped or murdered it was
probably william from tinder
last name i don't know he's in my phone
right
so she's leaving sort of electronic
footprint where she is
yes who she's going with okay can you
talk about
the juxtaposition of the opening lines
and how
um you're bringing comedy to the page
and
you already kind of have us laughing so
you're doing that but then at the same
time
you have this stark reality of like oh
whoa
that's kind of serious she's like
basically saying if i'm found
here's who might have done it yeah it's
like it's kind of have you ever uh
watched
a comedian i think maybe it's jim
jeffries or someone they talk about
have you ever read like a transcription
of a comedian's show and when you're
just reading it
you know without all the pomp and frill
of being on stage it can be a little
like
stark you're reading you're like holy
moly he said what
and it's kind of almost how i felt when
you were reading the the digital
footprint line i was like
we wrote that but no like when the movie
it's funny you know and it's all drawn
from
things that i've heard like stories i've
heard like true true anecdotes of like
girlfriends of mine who
maybe they're going to go on a date at
some bar like across town
and they they want someone to know where
they're at and it's kind of like it's
smart it's
you know i hope it comes off as cute you
know i think it's kind of funny because
she's
she's being very silly like she
if she really was fearing for her life
she obviously wouldn't go in there so
there's a little bit of that comedy
aspect of like just in case
you know it's a wild world out there on
digital dating apps
um but yeah i think that there's like
some comedy there and also some levity
to
we're all understanding that dating apps
can be you know
trashed in a really really terrible time
depending on who you swipe with
right okay after this you introduce us
to a parking enforcement officer
and again there's no character
description
do you think that having no character
description hurts or helps
with casting well with the casting
you know i obviously lean really heavily
on these like brand decks that i was
telling you about for each movie that
we're
going to make and so i had this deck
that really told exactly
who it is we're looking to cast now
again i think that that's probably not
the uh not common with writers like
there's a procedural way to do
everything and we're probably just a
little bit
non-traditional when it comes to that
but at the end of the day
i think that you can have a conversation
you can talk to the agent and be like so
this is who we're looking to cast like
can we
talk can we get one of your talents
we're looking at this person and this
person
and then they're going to read my pitch
deck and see all the branding and
coloring and then they're going to read
like maybe i've isolated a few pages and
i'm like you know this is the character
so obviously the
the agent's going to read the script
they already have the client in mind
that i've asked for
and so when they read the the dialogue
they know exactly what it is we're
looking for because they're thinking of
the client that we've asked for
um yeah i i'm i don't i don't know why
we don't
include descriptions i think we just
kind of like to leave it really
action-based in
in the in the you know non-dialogue
spaces
what are the questions that we ask
ourselves that make us want to turn to
the second page
well hopefully they want to know uh if
emma's going to get out of this parking
ticket
or and how her date at this potential
this guy we don't know i mean she's
going on a date where she's leaving a
voice memo for whomever might find her
phone so i hope that people are like all
right
she's she might be going on a disaster
date she just had a terrible
situation happen out on the curb with
this this parking
attendant uh and so what kind of
attitude is she going to have when she
even goes in on this date
so i think there's a little something
there to still uncover for the viewer
and the reader
is this still the opening of the movie
it is okay yes
unlike val this is a lock script and it
didn't it didn't really change other
than a little bit of improv on set
you know sometimes there were lines that
were said in a certain way like one of
my favorite
lines uh is said by kyle howard
and um it's the character emma is going
over to
his his house and she knocks on the
wrong door and he comes out and he says
uh that's that's my mom's door
you know knock knock come over to this
door and and she's like oh
sorry okay and then she goes and he's
like i'm just kidding and the
the original line was something like i
don't live with my mom
but one of our our gaffer thought he
said i don't have a mom
which is ludicrous like everyone like
literally has a mom so he ends up saying
like
i'm just kidding i don't have a mom and
i was just like it made everyone on set
laugh
and it still makes me laugh to this day
so i was like oh that state that stays
in there so i love a little bit of
improv on on set it was great
and plus it's funny too because she's
going on this date and then she's like
wait a minute
he lives either right next to his mom
exactly
so there's like first he's living with
his mom he doesn't have a mom what's
going on here it's like
full on and what do you love about this
first page
i think that it sets up the the tone
that we're gonna be with emma
first of all we're gonna be with emma
quite a bit and she's gonna be
struggling
you know you you kind of see some
actions from her she's she's silly at
heart obviously she's doing the southern
drawl and
kind of being fun with it she's leaving
this sort of ridiculous voice memo
but and then she's you know sort of
having to deal with this parking
attendant who's going to give her you
know some
some grief over that and i i just like
that it really does
foreshadow what's going to happen in the
rest of the film she's obviously she's
looking for love
she's looking for a real connection
she's a light silly fun person
she makes mistakes and she continues to
make mistakes throughout the entire
script just like she made a mistake and
not feeding the meter when she parked
you know and
and that's like the first page is
actually like this perfect uh
rendition of what we're going to be
seeing for her character in the entire
the entire film
and so forgive me so she's in the big
city i take it she's not initially from
wherever this is whether it's l.a um she
no i think she i think she's always
lived in los angeles i remember that
i don't think that we really get into
like where she's from or not and the
southern jaw thing is just she's just
like kind of joking around like she's
just
playing playing a little silly time with
herself
right so she's fun she doesn't take
herself too seriously but at the same
time she knows
i'm going on this date and i better just
make sure that everything's okay so i'll
leave this
right right she's a little bit neurotic
she's a little bit silly out there she's
she's kind of like how any of us could
be over the course of a month she just
happens to be
in like one minute of the opening of the
film
is there anything you wish you would
have done differently at the opening
with the opening
i can't really think of anything in fact
as we were chatting about it i thought
how great it is that everything that how
mia i'm sorry how emma
uh the actress that we cast her name is
mia um however everything that the
character of emma does in the opening
is perfectly reflective of what we're
going to be experiencing throughout the
rest of the film
and i do think that even the parking
attendant you know
scuffle where she's she's sitting at
this meter she hasn't paid the meter and
the
the eric griffin character who's the
parking attendant he says like well you
should have
paid the meter you know she goes through
a lot of that where she could have
actually just
done this one little thing and not been
in this predicament later she could have
just
had this one conversation with this guy
that she really liked
and not ended up thinking that he was
doing all these
you know terrible things behind her back
there was a lot of that where she just
could have helped herself so easily but
she didn't
and so that's very indicative of her as
a character throughout
and just on a personal note have you
ever had a confrontation with a parking
person my gosh i'm sure
they're terrifying um no i think that
if if i've got a ticket and i have
gotten a few tickets they're just
proudly red and white sitting on the
windshield waiting for my return
no meter made insider no meter human in
sight
i think we actually had one that let us
go we were doing an interview and we
didn't have a place
to interview the person so we
interviewed them in their car and the
person was going to give us a ticket
i was so lucky and we somehow charmed
them out of it and they were very nice
but yeah i know that's yeah
but it's a great opening because she
gets in this this argument with this
person
is it established whether they're male
or female i don't
think it is in fact we were we were
split we were really we were right down
the middle of who we would be casting um
because we had some some we knew we
wanted to go with the comedian we
thought like this role is 100 gonna be
for a comedian
um and and we could we knew we were
going to bookend that character it was
going to be an issue in the beginning an
issue she comes back in the end
with a little lesson learned there um
and so we were really split it could go
either male or female and she gets in
this argument
and then the meter person ends up kind
of like putting it back on her saying
well you're actually the jerk kind of
yeah yeah exactly
and she's being a little bit of a jerk i
mean he's being a teensy little bit of a
jerk but it's also his job you know so
you just have to
that's his job she was sitting in a
meter that was expired so
she and she's out there yelling at him
and following him down the sidewalk
she's being a little bit of a jerk and
he says it so
good for him stand up for the meter
humans of the world they're not always
the bad guys
you